power is being transformed in the uk
to get to net zero fossil fuels
largely consigned to history
the uk is the biggest importer in the
world of biomass or wood pellets
but in this critical year to stop the
clock on a climate disaster
burning wood for energy is facing fresh
scrutiny
along with the billion pounds the
government pays to subsidize it
trees play an important part in helping
to tackle climate change
they naturally soak up carbon but the
european union
is currently reviewing its policies
around the burning of wood to generate
energy
and there are calls for other countries
including the uk
to do the same jean pascal van impe
was vice chairman of the ipcc
the united nations body which assesses
the science on climate change
we are really creating a depth you know
a big carbon depth by burning
today that those pellets
that would in power plants because we
release the co2 now
hoping that future woods
will absorb co2 in the future
jean pascal is one of 500 scientists who
recently wrote to world leaders
calling for biomass not to be classed as
carbon neutral
they said we urge you not to undermine
both climate goals and the world's
biodiversity
by shifting from burning fossil fuels to
burning trees to generate energy
to meet future net zero emission goals
your governments should work to preserve
and restore forests
and not to burn them last year in the uk
biomass powered six and a half percent
of the national grid
data shared with sky news from the think
tank ember
calculated that two uk power stations
got just over a billion pounds in
subsidies
and were excused from paying carbon
taxes totaling over 300
million pounds to subsidize
um an activity that has
negative consequences for climate and
the environment
is is totally contradictory with the
goals of the paris agreement
and and the goals of the uh
the conference due to take place in
glasgow at the end of the year
drax power station in north yorkshire
sees itself as part of the climate
solution
not the problem and wants to be carbon
negative by 2030.
drax survived by switching from coal to
biomass
delivered by train almost all of its
biomass is imported
450 000 tons biomass pellet plant
owned and operated by drax in louisiana
nearly two-thirds of the wood pellets
used by drax come from forests in the
southern united states
drax says it's confident more carbon is
being stored than is being removed
whenever you remove wood from a forest
you have to account for this co2 that
you've removed
and that's the system which we work
under and the deity
so i'm aware there are cause for these
systems to be looked at do you accept in
any way
that the use of biomass is controversial
obviously i'm aware that some people
have concerns over biomass
what i would say is there's good biomass
and bad biomass
and you have to be really clear where
your biomasses come from
and be able to audit every part of that
supply chain
there's no dispute that the burning of
biomass emits more carbon than coal at
the smokestack
but as a renewable energy source the
emissions are not included in government
figures
if you did include emissions from the
new biomass we'd be making much slower
progress towards net zero than
than people tend to think so that means
having another look at the biomass the
policy framework surrounds the biomass
industry
the department of business energy and
industrial strategy
says subsidies are only given to biomass
which complies with strict
sustainability criteria and biomass is a
valuable part of the national grid
that may not satisfy environmentalists
who want the government to take
another look at the use of biomass in
this critical year for the climate
lisa holland sky news